be sure to follow me on instagram there
you can hang out with me and talk to me
directly
okay so we are picking back up with the
boys that's right every Tuesday it's the
boys you guys get the censored version
on YouTube and the uncertain one goes on
patreon for like a buck honestly I've
been trying to figure out what stories
I'm gonna do after this and I think I
know I think I know what to what use
series one of them's gonna be really
really long I think I know what two
series I'm gonna do after this people
who are follow me on patreon pretty much
know what the next one's gonna be but
one after that nobody knows yet so it'll
be kind of a cool surprise but this
picks up with the boys now the whole
thing here is that River the team is
basically transitioning to Moscow and
originally we didn't know why right
there's one of the cool things about the
way the Garth Ennis does this right he's
like the next stories gonna take place
in Moscow and you kind of have to go
read it in order to figure it out but
what we end up doing here
is picking up with this particular woman
named Nina Nina no Minko but she's
really referred to as like little Nina
but with these guys being here really
with the the boys arriving at around the
same time ultimately they're meeting
with a guy named Voss now of course
monkey is the one that picks him up
those guys who were sort of catching up
with us with Billy but you're working
with the CIA monkeys kind of the
intelligence guy he's the liaison
between Susan rayner who's the director
of the CIA and Billy butcher himself
which again allows for the agency to
sort of disavow him if things end up
going belly-up but with with monkey
basically meeting him here and then
saying hey look you know I'm taking you
guys to got me vas all that kind of
stuff we ended up picking up with boss
who was basically a member of a
superhero team at one point and it's
really sort of cool that the way this
plays out is because he was originally
part of a group that was called the the
glorious five-year plan now we'll get
more into that as time goes on but even
then within the confines of the story we
don't get a full-on explanation here
instead what you end up having is Billy
butcher in vas greeting each other as
exceeding the old friends and this
really kind of seems to fly in the face
of what we would expect from Billy
butcher enemies as a guy that vehemently
dislikes superheroes but the cool thing
about this is that Billy butchers
dislike a superheroes really seems to be
limited in scope - are you a superhero
who does crappy things now there have
been some offhanded comments he's made
when he was talking about talking about
starlight and like well it's all a
matter of time before she goes on and
does bad things and so on and so forth
so his friendship with various people
seems to be selective and it seems to be
one of those scenarios where if he comes
across someone who doesn't know they're
a superhero but they have an
exceptionally strong moral compass that
he agrees with or he can respect it also
Billy the fact that their superhero
seems to kind of go to the wayside
regardless of the other motivation and
the basis behind this all of them sort
of working together is just kind of like
hey we've got history and and so on and
so forth it's kind of funny because this
guy really
like like Voss's name when he was part
of the of the the five-year plan it was
love sausage and that'll become apparent
as to why here in a little while it's an
amazing name but ultimately he ends up
serving them some homemade some homemade
vodka now here's the thing I'm not
Russian nor have I ever hung out with
Russian people in their own country but
I have hung out with people in the in
the Appalachian so right like I had been
in Tennessee I used to live in Kentucky
I understand the notion behind like home
brewed alcohol let me tell you some it
was anything like moonshine I wouldn't
mess with a man like moonshine is
intense it's like it's like pure alcohol
it's absolutely insane but of course
here we can't handle him here we can't
handle his liquor which again I can't
really fault him for man you're talking
about home brewed vodka from Russia like
it's gonna be some pretty intense stuff
but nonetheless picking up with Nina she
actually ends up sitting down and in
meeting with a guy who seems pretty
clandestine now this conversation really
seems to be business oriented we'll find
out who this guy is as we go on but one
of the things that's also sort of
established here by the conversation
that takes place with Nina as well as as
what was the the morgue that Billy
butcher and his guys were taken to by
boss is it really sort of establishes
that Nina is a no-nonsense woman or
she's not someone to be trifled with
that when it comes down to it she's
cutthroat and she'll do whatever she
needs to do in order to ensure her plan
is achieved and so despite being a
diminutive woman she's not someone to
mess around with this really also gets
us into the meat and potatoes of what's
going on here because through Nina's
conversation with this guy as well as
Billy butcher and then being in the
morgue what we end up learning is that
we're compound v is is the substance
used by Vlad American and really by
pretty much all the superheroes out
there in order to have their powers that
other countries kind of wanted their own
thing as well right now this is really
uh this is really
Garth Ennis borrowing heavily from
Marvel and and probably other other
comics as well but off the top my head
pretty heavily from Marvel informs alike
the Super Soldier Serum Captain America
was project one and then you got a whole
bunch of other projects and eventually
you landed on Wolverine with project 10
with weapon ten but the desire to
duplicate the Super Soldier Serum of
Captain America is really how this
resonates with me right the idea that
what Nina seems to have done here is
gotten her hand on a variation of
compound v the issue with this is that
it's more of a team down version and so
because of that what this is done is
basically created a scenario whereby
people who were injected with this
altered version of compound V their
heads explode their heads end up blowing
up now it could happen one of two
waise the biggest way in the most
unreliable way is that once they're
injected with this at some point along
the line their head will block and you
don't know when it is right like they
use one instance where they say that
like some monkeys were injected with
this altered version of compound V and
it was like two years before one of
their heads blown up and and they were
sold to a zoo the other half of this is
that you can actually use a system to
intentionally detonate them why the kind
of radio frequency so to speak but the
long and short of it is that the the
compound that Nina's been using is 98%
affected right so it's not a pure
perfect version of compound rather but
it's relatively close and so it's an
interesting thing here because what it
does is kind of expand on things and so
it's kind of interesting here because
when when all this is going down and all
this is happening what's basically told
to Nina is that Billy butcher and his
crew are here in Moscow and that crew
needs to be stitched up why not the bat
is either a bought American horse the
government they're the only two people
that know they're Billy butcher and his
guys are here right like bought American
would know because they keep tabs on
Billy whoops you were following you know
homeland or realizing the Billy
butcher's back and then it would be the
the government because he works directly
with the CIA though the only two who
would really know and it's kind of funny
the way the Grant Morrison play I'm
sorry not Grant Morrison Barth and his
plays this he doesn't fast and loose
because it could be either one and where
Billy and his crew had been relatively
careful ultimately when they order a
pizza it ends up being revealed that
they've been noticed when they get a
face on their pizza more or less and
it's kind of interesting because this
feels more like a message than anything
else right you know like if we're aware
of you and it's only a matter of time
before you die but the other part of
this is that this guy who's here meeting
with Nina really has his own backup
system right like like things more or
less are being monitored here and it
seems to serve two purposes one it seems
to serve the purpose of keeping an eye
on needed and make sure things don't pop
off and even then it also seems to kind
of serve the purpose of being like an
insurance plan if Nina were to back out
or if you were decide she didn't to have
anything to do with it it would be like
hey look like we got you on camera we
can dump this out to the world so
everybody knows what you look like and
how to get a hold of you and in all I
kind of good stuff
or you can play ball and I mean it's
kind of a mishmash of different
possibilities here but ultimately she
ends up saying okay like like let's get
on to business right like let's sort
this stuff out so as a result of that
with Billy butcher and his team being
tracked down Nina seemingly sending her
her goons after them it's kind of cool
because what it shows us is that Billy
butcher is usually always aware and it's
very easy to sort of dismiss him as a
guy who's kind of painfully oblivious to
everything going on right the building
butchers a guy that never really I mean
he kind of knows what's going on but not
in the extreme and so what this does is
it actually has the goons of Nina
following
and then ultimately billy butcher does
mean like yet we're aware of them
he sends Frenchie over to basically
sniff them out and it figure out what's
going on to find a device in their car
to take him out and then in turn when
the final guy is is captured literally
Billy Bush forces him to spill the beans
right it's kinda like talk or I'm gonna
break every single bone in your body now
of course this guy dumps it all out
saying basically we're working for a
little Mena and that's all we really
know right I mean and that's true
they're hired guns their henchmen don't
really have any information they're
given some envelope somewhere and
they're told go take these guys out
there giving us the pictures you know
and that's it right I mean this guy is
these are nobody and so you could get
what information that you can and being
told who it is is coming after them is a
pretty solid piece of information
because it gives them an idea of who it
is and then they can in turn to do
intelligence and then figure out how to
basically stay hidden or it or to combat
that person head-on now the other part
of this and this is one thing that that
that really kind of gets thrown in here
but it'll become important later on is
you've got a guy named Joseph Jamaica
who's basically running for election
here right like a return to the old ways
of things trying to take Russia back to
the Communist days moving it away from
from capitalism and it's kind of cool
here because you have Voss who talked
about his time when he was a tank man
right now he says Afghanistan and the
knee-jerk reaction here would be to say
okay so he's talked about Afghanistan
during like the Iraq Afghanistan events
that are going on because this takes
place relatively close to the modern day
what he's actually referencing is a
soviet-afghan war of the 1970s right
that was a proxy conflict that took
place as part of the part of the Cold
War right that's why the Cold War isn't
really considered an actual war because
no flight was really engaged in between
like just Russia and the United States
wasn't like World War two where they
were like the two guys fighting each
other and then everybody else is sort of
joining in what you have a proxy
conflicts of the Vietnam War the Korean
War and the soviet-afghan war they were
basically the conflicts by which the
USSR was trying to spread their
communist influence and the u.s. was
trying to expand their capitalist
influence well that's the entire basis
behind the Cold War but ultimately Billy
butcherin and he we end up basically
kind of going on on a reconnaissance
mission of sorts to figure out what's
going on with this compound v that that
that mean is using what our intention is
and in where all these quote-unquote
superheroes are that are being
stockpiled by her because that's what
she's doing she's using compound video
inject it in people and then stockpiling
them somewhere and they end up finding a
warehouse where there's around 150
people all of whom has superpowers and
the question becomes if nina is
stockpiling superheroes then what you
gonna do with them that's kind of the
question that's being asked here and so
we actually get this full-on explanation
but what you end up doing is basically
kind of having Huey and Billy butcher
basically
split-off now it's kind of a cool little
moment here by Billy butcher I know I
say that a lot that it's a cool one but
it is right because Billy butcher seems
like a super hard-ass right like a guy
who just who's just a dick for the most
part but he's actually kind of got a
softer spot for hue which is sort of
cool to see and the way this really
plays out is when they split off you've
got the one guy who met with Nina
earlier and story who goes out and
continues on his thing and then you've
got the surveillance vans watching him
right that's we only fan a surveillance
van that he has working for him is kind
of going forward and so when they split
ultimately ends up being build a butcher
who takes a surveillance van and then
when these two really like hookers more
or less exit the van then he says here
we go and go and follow those hookers
and see what's going on now of course he
basically says hey look these girls seem
to be more distraction than anything
else did it really sir it seemed to
serve an actual purpose here they're
just really making a lot of noise over
in this area and the reason why is
because what it does is it allows the
surveillance van to actually go up and
and really like enter the tarmac and
then essentially like travel over to
Nina's plane and it's kind of a funny
thing because when Billy butcher gets in
there what he ends up realizing is that
like these guys are working for fought
American and it's kind of a big moment
there because what this says is that
this guy who the guy who met with Nina
is working for a bought American and so
what it shows is that it's not really
the government acting here it's just an
organization out there right like the
the marketing company more or less for
for the seven for the various
superheroes in the US is extending its
reach out into Soviet Russia and the
question becomes why but what we end up
learning here is that these guys we're
initially gonna plant explosives inside
the plane of Nina so that it was kind of
an insurance rider sheep try to bail out
on bald american oh do they could have
destroyed her basically they could have
taken her out it's a pretty smart move
in terms of having insurance there but
when Billy starts sweating through
everything and looking at all the stuff
that's there then it's kind of like wow
like she's a pretty naughty woman in the
sense that he seems to discover some
seems to discover the vibrators that she
that she had with her uh and then at the
same time is like let's see if we can't
put any of this stuff to use right so
it's kind of torturing this guy to a
degree getting the information he needs
this is when it transitions over to vas
making like this borscht for everybody
and here's the thing man boss seems like
the coolest guy ever right because
mostly he gives him like he gives it
like some straight-up homebrew alcohol
which depending on on your thing you may
you may enjoy I was never a big fan of
bathtub alcohol he's also making up like
home-cooked meals where this guy's like
the greatest host to ever man like
drinks and amazing food the issue with
this is that once they all start to go
through and eat the food that's when
Billy butcher begin to sort of dump the
information out to us in terms of his
specs
halation and what he believes is going
on and and this is actually one of the
coolest concepts and I've heard of in
comics in a long long time so the way
this played out it's so visceral and so
basic but so genius with Nina
stockpiling all these superheroes all
these super-powered beings and then
getting kind of like this this version
of compound V when she's talking about
like the ninety-eight percent
effectiveness what this means is like
like one the effect of compound V and
two the ability to destroy these
superheroes and the reason why is
because having like a radio device that
could literally detonate the brains of
these guys you know using this this
variant of compound V what Nina would do
issue an intern use the the compound
from Von American and then create all
these different heroes send them out
into Russia and then just let all hell
break loose and so that when the
government can't control it and the
government can't contain it well then
here she comes seemingly out of nowhere
and then activates you know basically
destroys these guys quote-unquote saves
the country and then now she's the new
leader and ultimately really working
with flawed American allowing them to
have more of an influence and in the
world use people's fear against them in
order to seize power the funny thing
about this is that you end up having
billy butch who says that's how nina
sees it from as far as her deal goes
that's not how it actually yes bought
american does not see her as reliable
they don't see her as controllable but
Joe Joseph jamendo
is and that's why he's currently running
for office being backed by I bought
American but nobody really knows and
what would happen is that bought
American would basically give Nina a
false detonator a detonator that
wouldn't work so all these superheroes
would begin to run awry everything would
pop off and then when she goes to
destroy the superheroes it wouldn't work
presumably they would give the detonator
to just a tomato or they would say like
we'll bring our superheroes over there
and then we'll basically kind of have a
bridge back and forth and we'll work
with each other but essentially just a
Tamiko would be nothing more than a
puppet for Vaught american it's a pretty
genius maneuver it's a pretty smart
maneuver the problem is that in the
middle of all this basically everybody
but Huey and and and vas end up passing
out now initially Huey freaks out right
he's kind of okay it's you like you're
the one that everybody's reporting to
your though you'd like to do the one
behind all this right and it's kind of
funny because initially it seems to play
off that way and it is one of those
things were it looks like that's the
case you know one because you have this
statement that's made by vas they are
living and it's almost kind of a look of
frustration like oh damn like it sucks
they were all supposed to die Huey was
supposed to supposed to pass out died
along with all of them but he was so
loved now of course vas is not working
with anybody right like he really is a
legitimate good guy and this comes by
way of the dog freaking out and then
basically these guys come running in vas
loses his mind destroys them all written
in a matter of seconds and then says
like the reason why we're not infected
the reason why you and I haven't passed
out is because we've been drinking that
brake fluid stuff that I've been making
uh and it's the reason why we're alive
here because it really acts as like a
counter to whatever was that they put in
that borscht and so we're not affected
we're gonna be fun and it really comes
down to the two of them to take
everything out and so if they really
kind of fly in here
you know they really jump in to the to
the base of like the the henchmen right
and of course this was a smart move by
little Nina is that she didn't really
she doesn't really work with like her
own hands but I mean she has her own
bodyguards but she doesn't really have
her own henchman and the reason why is
because if she had her own henchman and
one of them got caught they could
potentially spill the beans
there's no telling what they could have
overheard some small detail they heard
somewhere they could bring everything
crumbling down right because when you're
talking about organized crime it falls
under the RICO statutes so if you can
prosecute one you could prosecute them
all and you can extend all kinds of
different charges so on and so forth her
entire empire would come crashing down
around her but if all she ever does is
involve herself with like some some
underlings given like give them a letter
and some pictures and and and basically
say these are the targets and their
assignment is to take them out and they
never really have any involvement with
Nina that it means if they fail then who
cares it doesn't really matter at all
right I mean she'll kill them for
failing and then she'll go with somebody
else but because she's such a big player
is one of these things where everybody
wants to basically be the person that
works for her because the payout would
be so well now of course these henchmen
are taking taken out quick fast and in a
hurry there's not much going on there
but it's kind of a crazy thing because
when everything sort of dumped out well
you know that's this guy starts talking
to Huey and basically sort of sort of
spilling the beans between Huey and
polish they start to pick up things and
start to realize what's going on did
initially you know she was supposed to
meet with not American but ultimately
she ended up bailing out right eye
things have basically completely gone
south and so she was supposed to bail
out and so ultimately she ends up the
I'll boarding her plane is taking off by
the time they get there her plane is
gone and it's kind of a smart move
because when this witness goes down
of course like she basically grabbed her
vibrator to give herself some kind of
you know moment a moment of peace some
kind of respite and as soon as she turns
it on the plane explodes and that's when
you know funny out Billy butcher was the
one who basically put a bomb in her
inner vibrator it's kind of a crazy
thing right because it's it's really
always Billy butcher thinking ahead and
that's why I like him so much because
he's a lot smarter than he initially
seems to come off right Lacey seems to
be kind of a guy who's just who's kind
of not really a buffoon but a guy who's
sort of flying by the seat of his pants
but it's said that like he could fake
this bar head to say okay should we need
to take her out and we probably will
let's put a bomb and
one thing she loves the most right her
vibrator and like mix her off the field
because remember it's Billy but you're
usually working in superheroes in their
entirety and anybody who seems to kind
of use them for their own purposes so
the fact that he figured you know all
this stuff out and he planned ahead it's
really kunos to him and that's why Billy
butcher is one of the coolest characters
out there like it's really cool but
nonetheless that's when you get this
sort of of Revelation to a degree about
everything that was going on because
what you end up finding out is an in
addition to basically you know sacking
Nina Nina D'Amico little Nina what
bought American would have done is they
actually would have given the right
detonator to Joseph Jamaica well that's
what they would have done because and he
would have been the savior of Russia
right like he's a person people would
have elected without question because
this guy has the means to basically
combat the superhero threat going on in
the states and if something they don't
want to have to deal with there and so
it's a really really smart move like
that was kind of last hit bit of
information in terms of how it was all
gonna go down but that's the nature of
the piece is it's it's it's really kind
of Billy butcher traveling from one
place to the next but then once he ends
up meeting with monkey and after having
dumped all this information as Susan
laner in the CIA Sousa Reyna basically
says we're not gonna do anything with it
and ultimately it comes down to the
nature of fear and that's why I bought
American has really rose and and
maintained itself as such a powerful
organization because they have super
humans on their side by and large for
the most part there's no real way to
combat superheroes aside from other
superheroes turning on them somebody
with with super strength equal to or
greater than the various other
superheroes out there who have super
strength and so if you're a company like
that that's backed by super-powered
beings who the government can't really
cope with and then you're in turn a
government agency saying let's basically
try to take them out all the way take is
is what American sitting the entirety of
the seven and all the other superheroes
at their disposal directly to CIA and
the CIA is gone like that's basically it
right I mean just like tearing down the
government you know and saying like
we're just gonna run everything from now
on it wouldn't it wouldn't be that hard
for them to get fortunately the goal of
of on American well it does seem to be
having a lot of influence out there at
the moment it really seems to be like
serving as a means to control and be
like a powerful organization albeit not
ruling everything now as time progresses
thought Americans motivations will
become more clear and though they'll
become a lot more clear-cut as time goes
on but because of this because of the
fact that soon as Susan Elena's response
is you know we're not gonna do anything
with this and it's her like all these
other superheroes are still sitting in
the warehouse
billy butcher ends up getting the
detonator and then traveling to this
warehouse and killing all of them right
like wiping them all out as was kind of
it's a it's a pretty dark moment here
but it's just like get rid of
superheroes but it's the nature of Billy
butcher is what he
it's the role he plays as that's one of
reasons why he's so cool and so
intriguing is because for the most part
when it comes to his war against
superheroes no quarters given surrenders
not taken and no quarter is given it's
pretty intense and is pretty hardcore
but at the end of the day it does get
the job done so ultimately the group's
end up end up kind of going their own
separate ways this guy who was working
with Nina earlier and the story fought
American is gone like he ends up taking
off and heading back to the States so a
lot of merican sort of escapes once
again with their hands clean and having
not really had any exposed involvement
in anything except for the information
that Billy butcher collected that he
gave to the CIA we're not gonna they're
not gonna do anything with and that's it
like everybody else who was a party to
this it's gone as it's a cool thing
because of course you know this
basically wraps it up but it gets
awesome you know that's one of the
reasons why I like the boys the stories
are so well done and in there they're
organized and they're structured and
they're it kind of continues on but also
sort of wraps up the main story as it
exists so that be said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comments explain it make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the robb core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
purse